CES 2016 is under way I'm Peter Brown
for gamespot here with Justin hey walled
and VR is the talk of the show because
today oculus open pre-orders for the
rift headset which will cost six hundred
dollars far above people's expectations
and that's got a lot of people worried I
six hundred dollars is is more than the
cost of consoles at this point like
that's a not a great PC but when you
think about a mainstream audience and
what they're looking for that's more
than they want to pay for a laptop these
days it is oculus really ready for
mainstream success like I would argue
that they're not even going for
mainstream success at this point yeah
that doesn't actually seem to be the
case I mean obviously they would
probably say different but the case is
right it's really expensive but more
than that there is not enough software
to back it up now we tried a few new
demos at the show but as always these
are very small focused demos that aren't
working perfectly and when you're
charging six hundred dollars for a
premium piece of tech people expect it
to work really well out of the box
that's why the iPhone was such a success
right out of the gate it didn't sort of
have this adoption period people just
ran with it because it works so well in
smartphones were filling a gap of things
that we needed like the thing when you
think about your life now without a
smartphone without the ability to to use
google maps to use all these things that
are just so much a part of our lives
like i can't imagine what life was like
before the smartphone we are hasn't
solved that quite yet it doesn't just
need a scout killer game we've been
saying that from the beginning that it
it needs a killer app it has a software
suite me Valkyrie is that killer app but
just one game does not make a you know a
really viable platform which is what
this is because you're buying this
system for games that will only work
with these headsets and so if you look
at it from the software perspective it's
lacking the hardware is still lacking as
well I mean we've both been using these
headsets now for a couple of years and
there have not been these dramatic
improvements in resolution and field of
view that we saw after the first year or
two these have kind of slowed to a halt
and something that we're going to see
interesting for early adopters and I
think that they'll be fine with is that
all of these different platforms have
different input devices and I think
oculus azhar great I really feel that
they they're they're able to be used in
a lotta different ways which is
important you want something that's
going to be able to be usable across a
wide array of different software but it
is this still the final solution that I
I'm not so sure about it feels like the
demos that there
targeting of course work really well
with them but is it going to be well
work well with everything maybe not and
are you going to want to buy multiple
versions of these so many controllers or
one VR experience Oh probably not that's
just going to raise the price even more
yeah and back to your original point I
mean we're saying that this isn't really
oculus attempt at mainstream success
what this i think really is is a move on
their part to get that market share
early you know just say look we're on
the market we've got X amount of
pre-orders that's going to get
developers its own yet other hardware
manufacturers interested in working with
them and partnering on future projects
and more than anything for the long-term
success of VR and specifically oculus
those conversations and that momentum
has to start happening and this is
something that we see in all types of
technology in all other industries when
you think about Tesla Motors right now
they're targeting a really high-end
consumer and eventually that's going to
go to a mainstream audience you're going
to be able to get an electric tesla car
for under 30,000 all right now you can
and i think right now that's what our
kids is doing as well this is something
that's aimed at a very high end consumer
and eventually that's going to trickle
down that's going to meet what we need
and what the mainstream consumer wants
but we're definitely not there yet no
we're not so it really doesn't look like
oculus is ready for mainstream success
and maybe that's not what they're going
for but you know for some people this is
going to be a great product to buy
because they just want to get a taste of
you are you know away from an event in
the privacy of their own home I think
that they'll find some enjoyment but I
think for the average person six hundred
dollars is just way too much for more VR
coverage and for more from CES stay
tuned to gamespot com
you